boa tarde galera tudo bem
apesar de ele falar dessas coisas eu sou
uma pessoa bem descontraída uma pessoa
bem tranquila
basta você vê que parte da minha vida eu
lidei com essa galera da arara de skate
e eu tenho uma história talvez diferente
de outras pessoas que vão vir aqui
porque eu fui criado numa região que é
bem gueto mesmo assim eu sou o cara que
eu sair quase da favela não da favela
mas quando vim de são paulo por exemplo
morava na rua de trás da favela e aqui
em indaiatuba também eu sempre morei no
subúrbio então eu cheguei à conclusão de
que às vezes falta a referência na vida
das pessoas e é isso que eu vim falar um
pouco aqui que é comum por cento da
população pode mudar o futuro do brasil
hoje nós estamos vivendo uma situação
econômica caótica uma situação de
descrédito total com a nossa política e
várias outras situações mas hoje eu faço
eu vou contar um pouquinho da minha
história eu sou filho de uma professora
que não é formada na verdade minha mãe
dava aula de reforço porque ela era
muito boa com isso mas nem terminar o
terceiro colegial ela terminou o meu pai
estudou até o quarto ano e ele é pintor
e quando a gente mudou que prender atua
com cinco anos que eu fiz com cinco anos
de idade ele deu dois livres de palavra
cruzada para mim e minha mãe me ensinou
a ler e escrever esses dois vídeos
palavra cruzada e eu aprendi com minha
mãe é uma coisa muito importante que
mudou toda a minha história que é filho
leia porque a leitura vai mudar como
você vê o mundo
eu aprendi outra coisa muito impactante
do meu pai meu pai no destino um cara
ferrenho cada trabalhador
ele me disse uma coisa filho trabalho
porque quem não trabalha não consegue as
coisas na vida trabalho seja honesta eu
cresci com isso então com 11 anos meu
pai me levava pra trabalhar
eu com 12 anos lia muito e estudava e
com 14 e 15 anos de idade já tinha lido
mais 150 títulos é claro que gostava de
ser vagalume agatha christie gibi
esse tipo de coisa e com 16 anos da
minha vida então mudou totalmente quando
eu fui trabalhar numa loja de skate eu
fui vendedor e eu aprendi que vendedor é
uma área que as pessoas acham que só
porque só o trabalho
mas se você quiser ser uma pessoa de
alta performance você precisa estudar
estudar muito para ser um vendedor de
sucesso e com 18 anos de idade
eu né que foi criado no subúrbio com
muitas referências negativas mas muitas
referências positivas por conta das
leituras das medicações
o que fazer então eu com bastante
bagagem mas pouca experiência
tive uma filha com 18 anos de idade e aí
que o negócio começou a ficar diferente
falei cara e agora que eu faço e era um
menino muito esperto não abrirei que
porque era um menino muito esperto eu
parei de estudar o primeiro colegial
porque eu fui me dedicar somente à dança
e aí com 18 anos eu tive uma filha então
voltei pra escola e comecei a me dedicar
a esse projeto e dois anos depois abrir
uma empresa que hoje dia 24 agora
completa sete anos que a peste w board
shop e quando eu abri a loja percebi que
precisava de mais informação e essa
minha ânsia por leitura essa minha ânsia
por querer mais me fez querer aprender e
me fez querer viver novas cenas e
praticar porque meu pai falava de pensar
morreu o burro eu percebo hoje que as
pessoas pensam muito reagem muito pouco
agem muito e pensam muito pouco então o
ideal é a balança e o que falta talvez
para onde estamos caminhando
o que eu vejo o que fez a nossa geração
fica olhando a geração passada geração
que inventou o carro a geração que
inventou eletricidade
a geração que inventou o computador
geração que inventou o smartphone
geração que inventou o avião e o que fez
a nossa geração talvez muito pouco ou
quase nada porque hoje inventar uma
coisa chamada google e aí as pessoas
onde elas pensam muito pouco porque o
google pensão por elas
e aí a gente está na era do conhecimento
o conhecimento é horizontal as pessoas
sabem muito mais sabe fazer muito pouco
eu já ouvi falar engraçado que o do
palestra ou nas empresas
para nós isso aí eu já ouvi em vários
lugares engraçado então por que você não
consegue fazer já que você sabe por que
você não aplica é porque não trabalha a
ação não trabalha a performance ela fica
só no pensamento normalmente e como nós
somos criados para quem tem mais aqui de
25 ou 30 anos participou de uma geração
que começava se muito cedo o primeiro
pelo espelho do pai porque o pai ea mãe
estavam próximos porque não precisava se
trabalhar tanto então ele já começava
ali a menina
já desde cedo o pai levava para
trabalhar ou colocava para trabalhar com
11 12 13 anos 12 anos e 13 a gente já
fazia senai naquela época e hoje o que
mudou hoje com as políticas às políticas
de hoje mudaram os políticos normalmente
fazem leis para ganhar voto política
assistencialista e não política pra
melhor e crescimento duradouro de uma
nação e as leis às vezes não ficaram tão
favoráveis então hoje os valores estão
se invertendo
porque os filhos mandam nos pais e não
mais os pais mandam os filhos quer dizer
o capitão combina vaca é o poste que
está viajando no cachorro é muito
engraçado porque tem um primo meu que
tem um menino de dois anos e eu fui na
casa dele ele falou vamos almoçar filho
ele falou assim não não vou mostrar eu
quero um danone
eu falei que não era seu filho almoçar
não porque ele falou que é um danone
mas quem quer um adulto aqui a mas ele
não quer então se percebe como inverter
os valores o ensino na outra geração era
totalmente diferente o professor era a
pessoa que era reverenciada que tinha
mais autoridade do que o seu próprio pai
que sua própria mãe
e no que o país ou no que a situação
transformou esses profissionais são os
profissionais que talvez não sejam
melhores remunerados desvalorizados
estressados com carga horária eu
contratei um menino de 16 anos na minha
loja que um dia ele chegou para mim e
falou cara fiquei muito triste porque eu
descobri que com 16 anos de idade sendo
vendedor ganha comissão ganham mais do
que o meu professor de geografia que
trabalha em três horários e como você
fazer e aí vai fazer faculdade curso de
pedagogia é um dos mais baratos que tem
279 pode fazer por ensino à distância e
é essa pessoa que vai cuidar dos filhos
eu tenho muita preocupação com o futuro
porque tenho duas filhas e eu percebo o
quanto falta a referência do ensino e o
que nós podemos fazer para mudar isso
porque se eu vim lá de baixo
sem uma realidade totalmente diferente
convivendo com pessoas que já morreram
conviveram com pessoas foram presas
conviver com todo o tipo de pessoas eu
conseguir fazer algo diferente o que
aconteceu
qual foi a medida e qual será o nosso
futuro como será isso nos próximos
este ano porque eu só vejo na tv que
está piorando eu leio estadão ler as
manchetes e não vejo solução
o que fazer então e aí trabalhando com
comércio fui desenvolvendo estudando
muito e comecei a treinar as pessoas
treinar todos os dias porque acreditei
num cara que era palestrante só pessoa
de muita fé o carvão sem treinar as
pessoas todos os dias e eu comecei a
treinar as pessoas todos os dias eu
percebi que só chegava comigo com 16
anos e 17 anos aquelas coisas que elas
não aprenderam na casa delas elas
conseguiam aprender comigo pela
repetição e pela mudança de paradigma
pela informação pela experiência porque
o ensino na escola é chato não atrai
se você trazer para a realidade das
pessoas elas querem expor a vida delas e
as pessoas passavam ficavam o tempo
comigo e elas iam atrás dos sonhos delas
os objetivos dela e com as histórias
parecidas com as minhas
então é possível mudar e aí quando fui
estudar coach quando fui estudar pnl eu
percebi a mecânica disso que o ser
humano ele aprende por mudança de
paradigma por mudança de crença e por
repetição para potencializar a hábitos
positivos para você fazer tanto uma
coisa que aquilo torne parte de você
então eu criei um projeto de uma marca
de custo zero para auxiliar empresários
a princípio ea gente disponibiliza
informações que os meus professores dos
meus mestres inclusive um saque também
estão presentes juntaram junto com a
gente a gente começou a ajudar pessoas e
as pessoas falar na cara isso é muito
legal porque eu percebi que as pessoas
sabem o que fazer mas elas não sabem
como fazer porque o conhecimento
universal mas a experiência única como
as pessoas agem muito pouco e passam
metade do dia só nas redes sociais e
pesquisando coisas que não vão levar
elas em direção ao sonho delas a ação
fica secundária
então nesse projeto a gente começou a
ver que era possível sim e eu comecei a
fazer palestras em redes públicas e eu
ia lá 100 pessoas 120 pessoas a diretora
falava tomar cuidado porque o último
palestrante que ver ele jogar um pedra
jogar o papel pelo amor de deus eu
ficava uma hora falando e eles ficavam
assim cara eu quero fazer isso percebe a
eu vou pensar sobre isso não eu quero
fazer isso
então se uma reflexão pode levar a ação
imagina repetição de um hábito o quanto
pode mudar
é por isso que eu digo que 1% da
população pode mudar o futuro da nação e
o que faz a diferença
o que faz a diferença não é o
conhecimento é o comportamento porque o
comportamento te leva a tomar atitudes e
ações que levem direção aquilo que é
correto
então o que falta hoje em ray gado nosso
país comprometimento nas empresas sejam
elas pequenas ou grandes quem tem
compromisso com o horário hoje quem
responde aquilo que falou promete e não
cumpre o compromisso hoje é uma coisa
que ficou esquecida empatia as pessoas
se colocarem no lugar das pessoas ver o
lado do outro se preocupar com o outro
respeito proatividade
as pessoas hoje estão esperando alguém
mandar elas fazer enquanto pessoas com
18 anos com 20 anos com 22 anos que não
descobriu ainda qual é o sonho dela
ele está falando de uma maioria da
população e não de uma minoria que tem
essa oportunidade comunicação as pessoas
comunicam muito mal tanto dentro de casa
quanto o irmão quanto o amigo né porque
elas são egoístas e aí a comunicação não
flui
eles se técnicas de comunicação existe
forma de você aprenderá comunicada legal
se comunicar mal porque lê pouco
eu fiz uma pesquisa e descobriu que no
brasil existe um livro e meio pra cada
habitante na frança esse número é de 20
fiz outra pesquisa descobri que na
colômbia é 2 livre e meio por habitante
ou seja na colômbia disse mais livre no
brasil proporcionalmente falando e que
na índia eles ler quase três vezes mais
do que a gente olha que coisa absurda
gestão do tempo as pessoas hoje não
sabem definir prioridades precisa que
diz que as pessoas gastam de quatro a
cinco horas por dia em redes sociais
na média geral e existe mais de 300
milhões de tablets computadores
smartphones hoje no país
então é um desperdício de tempo e as
pessoas dizem que não têm tempo para o
sonho é porque não tem prioridade então
a gente pode ensinar
jovens a pensarem gestão de recursos
não sei se vocês sabem mas hoje as
pessoas de 18 a 30 anos 52% da população
tem o nome sujo 52 por cento dos jovens
de 18 a 30 anos tem o nome sujo porque
porque o pai ea mãe não ensinou gerir o
recurso eles não têm dificuldade porque
o pai a mãe dá tudo
essa é a realidade porque na outra
geração era comum você chegar com 18 20
anos e ter recursos de poupança quem
poupa hoje quem poupa hoje então eles
não sabem administrar o recurso e isso
causa um estrago na nossa nação porque
não sei se vocês sabem mas cada de um
real investido na economia movimenta até
10 ou seja se eles estão gastando estão
devendo o país não está movimentando o
capital nós viemos nós vivemos no
capitalismo que a única forma é o
consumo consciente ea manutenção do
recurso é muito simples isso ea
criatividade a criatividade hoje não é
explorada nas escolas porque ensina é
ridículo você tirar sim você pode dormir
três horas na aula que ainda você
consegue tirar 5 é verdade eu sei porque
eu era um aluno assim e na escola escola
entediava com uma faculdade que eu fiz
também
em determinado momento entediava porque
não têm estímulo porque você não vê como
você pode usar aquilo na sua realidade
porque não tem prática porque não tem
visão real daquilo
você não sabe até hoje porque você vai
usar a forma de basca para você aprender
o quilo ea resiliência hoje as pessoas
elas são criadas a pão de ló né mamãe
traz o toddy na cama e aí o filho vem
chorando mamãe papai abraça mas o mundo
um lugar triste escuro e sombrio e você
precisa achar o sol e praticar o sol é a
lei da selva você precisa ser um animal
preparado porque um leão criado em
cativeiro é um gatinho é um gatinho hoje
a nossa população cria gatinhos e como
fazer para mudar isso
então o que nós pensamos melhor
opcionais melhores pessoas então a gente
pode pegar um por cento da população 2
milhões de pessoas na base e trazer
profissionais para ensinar essas pessoas
a serem melhor através de treinamento de
comunicação treinamento de gestão de
tempo interatividade com 12 anos 13 anos
imagina se você pegar essa galera na
base e formar através do que de parceria
com empresas porque as pessoas que
trabalham em empresas hoje qual é o
maior dificuldade o capital humano
as pessoas são preparadas e os que são
preparados custou muito caro e é por
isso que hoje além dos impostos negócio
vai muito lento porque é uma empresa
hoje normalmente uma pessoa no brasil
tem que fazer o trabalho de três
primeiro porque custa caro segundo
porque ela é despreparada e aí o gerente
tem que se virar com o que tem
imagine uma realidade que as empresas
recebessem esses adolescentes preparados
pelo menos em questão de comportamento e
não tecnicamente para fazer um trabalho
diferenciado um trabalho na base e onde
onde está o mundo o mundo hoje está na
sua mão está nos celulares
então imagina de disponibilizar
treinamentos gratuitos que você pode
acessar seu celular
e como a gente vai fazer para estimular
essas crianças primeiro existe duas
coisas que levam você sucesso cooperação
e competição é importante a gente ter um
time e é importante a gente competir
para crescer porque quando a água bate
na bunda
você tem que se mexer néné e é isso que
acontece
então como faríamos isso iríamos nas
escolas por exemplo tá todo mundo me
ouvir
iríamos nas escolas por exemplo fazer
parcerias
pra quê palestrantes vinculados ao nosso
projeto fosse lá fazer palestras para
essas pessoas para que elas pudessem
aderir ao projeto sem custo nenhum e
envolver toda a família nesse projeto e
através de recursos que viriam das
indústrias
nós iríamos sortear smartphones viagem
então a gente vai estimular através de
games através dessas coisas você vai
estimular o ensino até que aquilo se
torne parte de quem ela é porque a
repetição
leva à perfeição e é isso que nós
defendemos estímulos visuais coisas que
interajam com ela coisa que ela goste
financiamento do projeto via através por
exemplo de leis como a lei roney lei do
audiovisual existe uma diversas coisas
ou de patrocínio próprio investimento em
marketing mesmo das empresas porque as
empresas hoje elas estão sofrendo por
conta disso e cada dia que passa é mais
difícil você encontrar pessoas com
comportamentos adequados pra povoar os
locais que você precisa da empresa
então seria muito vantajoso a gente
criar uma nação que saiba fazer as
coisas imagine você 2 milhões 1% da
população 2 milhões de pessoas que
saibam realmente ler interpretar que
saibam votar que saibam escolher o
candidato que saiba dizer não quando
deve dizer não que seja proativa
imagina o impulso disso na nossa nação
porque toda a revolução começou com
menos de 1%
você vai obrigar o seu amigo por
competição a ser melhor porque o mercado
vai ficar mais acirrado
você vai obrigar os políticos a fazerem
menos merda porque ali tem pessoas que
estão de olho e aí você começa base a
uma nação para que daqui 30 anos 50 anos
70 anos a gente possa ir embora e deixar
nossos filhos aqui para não se preocupar
com o futuro e ser diferente não é fácil
porque pra fazer isso nós temos que na
contramão do mercado não sei se você
sabe mas nos países desenvolvidos 1% da
população só não vai depender do governo
na aposentadoria nos países
desenvolvidos no nosso país
essa estatística é de 0,1 por cento ou
seja as pessoas de sucesso é uma para
mil
então imagina a gente implantar uma
mentalidade dessa precisa do que dez
primeiras empresas acreditarem que
precisa começar agora na formação da
consciência na formação das habilidades
na formação do futuro porque hoje eu
olho pra nossa nação e o que eu vejo é
tudo igual
mas se a gente trabalhar nas nossas
crianças trabalhar nossos adolescentes
ou mesmo nos adultos que
irão fazer parte dessa revolução talvez
a gente possa olhar e ver algo diferente
têm todos uma ótima tarde e vamos fazer
toda a diferença